if you hate ascetics and things don't
you I don't love them but don't you like
you choose jobs to avoid them after
Voldemort I did I have much of that as
prosthetics on Baltimore actually to be
on volume on not so much there a lot of
paintings oh yeah
there was no moment when you kind of
knew the Voldemort look was working when
you were on set I knew who you met I
passed by the script supervisor has a
little boy he was on set his son may be
her son I think four five years old
anyway I passed by this little child I
just looked at this boy he is burst into
tears
to the cost you musta helped as well
because it's quite frightening the
costumes actually wasn't that it was
just a lot of flowing silky stuff that I
kept tripping over these tights on
underneath and they were ladies tights
they're not the sort of tight see we're
at the RSC oh okay probably what
happened was that the tights used to
work their way down to the gust the
gusset of the type around my knees so I
couldn't walk as elegantly island as I
would like as well them all so
eventually then I said to the dresser
could he's gone Neil he's very sweet
he was always had his head up my skirt
trying to adjust these and I said would
you mind cutting them off so I had a
garter belt so for most of Harry Potter
underneath the robes
I have very nice garter belt you spotted
for everyone now
John Hannah right yeah I wouldn't mind
looking like him there looks tough she's
a tough character your Camila yes he
vapes Rouladen she's you know dealing
with horses a lot and she picks up the
phone and it's Charles Dawes hello sexy